celebrities have access to personal
trainers expensive makeup and the best
style is to transform their look in the
blink of an eye
while some celebs have upgraded their
appearance throughout the years others
have seen their looks fade and they're
barely recognizable these days if this
is your first time visiting our channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up because
today we're sharing celebs most dramatic
transformations Bella Hadid before Bella
Hadid was ripping the runway and
dominating the modelling industry
she was an all natural California girl
she wore very little makeup she loved to
keep her hair messy and her outfits were
always cool and casual these days Bella
has completely morphed into a vamp
eviction her hair is a bit darker and
longer her makeup is always on point and
whenever she gets dressed up to go out
she's sure to turn heads with her skin
tight and revealing outfit Emma Watson
Emma Watson won us over as Hermione
Granger in the Harry Potter films she
was just 11 years old when the first
film was released and she has been
flossing into a gorgeous and beautiful
Hollywood starlet these days emma has
traded in her Hogwarts uniform for more
sophisticated and grownup style her hair
is sleek and stylish and she can be
found on the red carpet wearing the most
lavish designer gowns Freddie Prinze jr.
it seems like only yesterday Freddie
Prinze jr. was every girl celebrity
crush
the actress perfect face and mesmerizing
smile captivated us in movies such as
shoes all that in summer catch but
Freddie's heartthrob days seemed to be
over he has traded in his boyish good
looks for a manlier look complete with
gray hair okay I guess we all have to
grow up at some point Justin Bieber
when Justin Bieber emerged on the music
scene everyone was fascinated by his
baby face and it's scooped hair that
made him look like he was perpetually
stuck in a windstorm over the years his
face and body of change thanks to
puberty of course Justin went from a
sweet and innocent preteen to a muscular
manly man and wait a second is that
facial hair we see it's official
everyone the Biebs has finally entered
manhood Khloe Kardashian after
separating from ex-husband Lamar Odom
Khloe Kardashian was too
to drop some weight get into shape and
completely transform her body
the reality star was some help from
celebrity trainer Gunnar Peterson is now
more toned and fit than ever
she says she's determined to keep up
with her health and fitness regimen and
she hopes to be an inspiration for
others one look at her before and after
pictures and we're definitely inspired
to get our butts in the gym
Dona Hill Jonah Hill has always been the
lovable and funny sidekick in some of
our favorite movies such as super bad
and get him to the Greek but is it
possible that he'll be leaving a
sidekick days behind and taking on the
hunky lead role in major films it's
totally possible especially since he's
transformed its body
Jonah reveals a much smaller frame on
the red carpet and he's definitely
looking better than ever
Rob Kardashian at the start of Keeping
Up with the Kardashians
Rob Kardashian was the hot and fit
younger brothers who had girls all over
the world screaming his name but over
time the weight crept up on him and Rob
is now almost unrecognizable after
getting engaged to blac Chyna he got
back in the gym and started eating
healthy but it seems as if he has put
his weight loss goals on the back burner
for now and his physical transformation
is definitely shocking taylor swift you
remember when taylor swift debuted her
song love story' back in 2008 right she
wore her hair and bouncy blond curls
never left home without her dark
eyeliner and when it came time to dress
up she stuck with traditional and
elegant styles now that she has crossed
over from country to pop music she has
elevated her style to the singer
completely chopped off her hair bleached
it and is now rocking some pretty edgy
all-black outfit we have to hand it to
her the rocker looks definitely suits
her don't you agree Miley Cyrus we're
still not sure how Miley Cyrus managed
to go from a sweet and lovable Disney
star into a tongue obsessed rebel in her
Hannah Montana days Miley was all about
cute and girly outfits perfectly styled
hair and natural looking makeup but now
that she's ditched her Disney persona
she's embracing the more laid-back style
and unleashing her inner hippie her
outfits are fun and eccentric and you
can usually spot her in a rainbow print
tea or an outfit covered in smiley faces
ariana grande ariana grande has her
own signature look but she wasn't always
sporting a high ponytail tiny skirts and
over-the-knee boots before this
dangerous woman was making us all walk
from side to side she was just a typical
girl with naturally curly hair that she
sometimes straightened and dyed red
although these before and after pictures
were taken at least five years apart we
can't help but be shocked by her
transformation it's almost like she
morphed into a completely different
person right before our eyes which one
of these celeb transformation shocked
you the most react in the comments
section down below and don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up
you